Whitney was on a national team with
people I looked up to and and you know
she always come back with like
autographs and stuff and I was like I
want to do that I'm getting 52 more
practices than everybody else is let's
kind of make that little or big
difference in the end you know if you
want to do something and you want it
that bad
you'll make sacrifices you know the
people before me set the bar so high and
and I was a little kid that wasn't
afraid to dream as big as I could
he's an American competitive swimmer and
the most decorated Olympian athlete of
all time he also holds the all-time
record for Olympic gold medals his
international titles and record-breaking
performances has earned him the title of
world swimmer of the Year seven times
he's Michael Phelps and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success rule
number three is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best I had two older sisters that I
kind of looked up to and and for them
having the chance to travel nationally
and internationally you know my Whitney
was on a national team with people I
looked up to and and you know she always
come back with like autographs and stuff
and I was like I want to do that I want
to be on those teams I want to travel
the world and and at that point I was
just like you know I want to be an
Olympic gold medalist I want to break a
world record and I want to be
professional athlete and those goals
that I thought about every single day
kept me coming week after week in year
after year until I was able to
accomplish it what struck us most about
Michael when we met him all those years
ago was his dedication to the long hours
in the pool it's one reason why we
trained seven days a week while we
trained on Christmas while training
Thanksgiving 365 days a year however
many clubs are trained seven days a week
so it gives you one extra set training
session every single week where you can
pick something up so I mean I'm getting
52 more practices than everybody else is
let's kind of make that little or big
difference in the end
what do you feel separates good athletes
from the best athletes
I think it comes back to what I was
saying earlier about me I think it's a
lot of this mental you know if you want
to do something and you want it that bad
you'll make sacrifices and growing up
for me as a kid I made a lot of
sacrifices that I didn't seem that they
were a big deal and I don't seem like I
don't think of them being as being a big
deal right now you know there were
Saturdays or Fridays where I give up
going to a dance or hanging out with my
friends cuz I had workout the next day
but those things that I gave up you know
were things that I wanted to to help me
get to my goal and and there were times
where but you know I've been put in
uncomfortable situations but I've used
my mental power my mental strength to
push through it I think that's how you
you know you can look at any of the
athletes in the world
I mean Tiger the guys if a busted knee
and still comes and destroys the rest of
the field you know that's the thing like
people don't make excuses
some of the best at they're the greatest
athletes in the world do things when
they're uncomfortable you know everybody
can compete when they're feeling good
happy excited rested but it's the best
people who can overcome when they're
tired sure not in the great mind not in
the best mindset I think mental power
that the greatest athletes have can push
all the pain aside you know and I mean
like when I was doing that Navy SEALs
thing it was easy for me to do it no it
was easy for me to climb over a 45 foot
wall and look down not at all and I'm
afraid eyes but you know I said to
myself I'm going to do this and no one's
gonna stop me I think that's the biggest
thing is how strong you can be mentally
I think that really shows who the person
is so I think that's one thing that
separates the good from the great
I think that just keep the I just keep
the ball rolling
um I like to I guess have some more best
times and other events maybe a closer
world records in those I don't know um I
think that I smiled my long-term goals
so when we gold medal in Athens and go
on more than one event so I mean I have
a lot of goals but I think that I just
want to take day-by-day Michael Phelps
was a force of nature who was preparing
to take on the world and win his first
Olympic medal at that GS Athens Games
he stood six foot four with a wingspan
of six foot seven the then 18 year old
had already established himself as the
world's fastest ever all-round swimmer
and at this stage in his career he held
three World Records and three world
titles but his big aim was to win
Olympic gold in Athens and not just one
he was looking to equal or even exceed
mark Spitz's record haul of seven gold
medals from the 1972 Olympics many
including Australia's Ian Thorpe thought
Phelps's mission impossible I think if
he said that that means it's what he
actually he can't do I don't think it's
impossible for anybody
I mean I think if you really just have a
wide open mind and use your imagination
I think a lot of things are possible I
think of myself as the greatest person
that I can be that's it
I'm not going to go out of my you know
ad out on the limb and say I'm the
greatest this or that I just I was a kid
with a dream that's it and and you know
the people before me set the bar so high
and and I was a little kid that wasn't
afraid to dream as big as I could and
that's really it I you know like you
said like we were talking before it I
was dedicated I was hard working and
that put me in the shoes where I am now
ever since I've moved to Arizona
it's it's been so wild to me to see so
many people that have come up and just
been supportive and and I think that's
something really special because it goes
hand it goes back to what I wanted to do
with the sport and being able just to
know that this person or that person is
watching the random bar down the street
or random restaurant down the street
I've changed things in the sport and
I've done what I wanted to do and there
are people back home and we are overseas
that are screaming their brains out and
there's nothing cooler like like when I
come home and hear just the stories from
them and those little times you know
could change someone's life could pick
somebody up it's just an honor for me
this time his retirements for real even
though he claimed the same thing after
London I remember saying to you are you
done you said I'm done I'm done I said
the great ones never retire me you are
in Russia sugar ray you said no no no
but you were you were bummed you weren't
you weren't loving swimming at that time
hated it I wanted nothing to do with the
sport then
and that's why I came back but and I
didn't want to end my career like that
but I had to find the passion myself
again and and I found that again and I
had fun and this was this is how I
wanted to fit how I what I did here is
the best what happened in since London
and Rio in those couple years that
turned the lights back on um I guess I
just started being me and found who I
was and was happy with who I am and
that's what everybody's gonna see and
that's what everyone has seen over the
last two years me being me and being a
kid and loving what I'm doing and being
able to start a family there were a lot
of mixed feelings after that race I
wasn't happy with the time but
afterwards like I saw the time and was
like man it's really like I'm not happy
with that and then I realized that I had
made my fifth Olympic team and you know
that was something that that after
London I didn't think was possible
taking some time off going through some
ups and downs and being able to get to
the obstacles that I had to be able to
have the chance to swim on my fifth
Olympic team it's just special to not
only be on the team again and represent
my country but also have the chance to
have my son come and watch my last films
ever he might not remember him but I'll
have the memories for life I don't I
don't really live the normal life this
teenager I mean I get a lot of there I
give I guess I'd give up a lot of things
but I mean I'm getting tons and tons of
other things that normal 15 year-olds
aren't getting so I think that I think
this is a life that anyone could dream
of and I'm definitely loving it thank
you guys so much for watching I made
this video because Sam to to 9a asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do I also love to know which of
the top ten rules from Michael Phelps
had the biggest impact on you meant the
most to you and why leaving in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion finally I'll give a quick
shout out to Q Levin thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book do you
guys watching if you want to change at a
shadow in a future video make sure to
grab the
but also email in your receipt so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
your one word is and I'll see you soon